[Music]
Nana watt weakest of the Aztec gods
sickly and covered in pimples had been
chosen to form a new world there had
already been four worlds each set in
motion by its own Lord Sun and each in
turn destroyed the first by Jaguars the
next by winds the next by rains of fire
and the force by floods to establish the
fifth son Lord Quetzalcoatl serpent had
gone to the underworld and returned with
the bones of earlier people nourishing
them with his own blood to create new
life but for them to have a world to
live in another God had to leap into the
great bonfire and become the fifth son
the Lord of sustenance and the Lord of
fire had chosen not a wat for this test
while the Lord of rain and the lord of
the four quarters had picked their own
offerings the proud rich Texas Tech hunt
first the chosen ones had to complete a
four day fasting and bloodletting ritual
Nana wand had nothing but cactus thorns
with which to bleed himself and fir
branches to paint with his red offering
but he resolved to try his best
meanwhile Texas TECA he flaunted his
riches using magnificent Jade spines and
branches adorned with iridescent Quetzal
feathers for his own blood offering when
four days had passed the fire was
roaring high four times proud Texas Tech
on approached the flames and four times
he pulled back in fear humble nanawatai
stepped forward the other gods painted
him chalky white include feathers to him
without hesitation he threw himself into
the flames a fire blackened Eagle
swooped over the fire grabbed to nunna
wat and carried him into the sky their
Lord and Lady sustenance bathed him sat
him on a feathered throne and wrapped a
red band around his head inspired by
Nana wat taxis ticket threw himself into
what was left of the fire cooled ashes a
Jaguar jumped over the fire pit but
couldn't carry taxis ticket into the sky
when tech sees tech out reached the
horizon a band of goddesses trust him in
rags still he shined just as brightly as
nanobot but since he had shone far less
bravery and much more pride one of the
gods picked up a rabbit and tossed it in
his face
dimming his life but the fifth world
still wasn't truly established Nana watt
Lord Sun shined for four days straight
without moving through the sky like all
the previous Suns had moved back in
their home teotihuacan the gods began to
worry
they sent obsidian Hawk up to ask what
was wrong the Nahuatl replied that just
as he had sacrificed himself to become
Lord Sun he now needed the nourishing
blood of the other gods in order to move
through the sky enraged at the
suggestion Lord dawn stepped up and shot
an arrow at Lord Sun Lord Sun shot back
and his Quetzal feathered arrow struck
Lord dawn in the face turning him to
frost before anyone else could act
rashly the other gods turned to each
other to discuss what to do of course no
one wanted to sacrifice themselves but
nor did anyone want to act like Lord
dawn
besides Nana watt had held up his end of
the bargain to nourish the earth how
could they refuse to nourish him in
return they remembered how even the
wimpy tech sees TECA had eventually
managed to emulate Nana Watts bravely at
long last five other gods agreed to
sacrifice themselves one by one more
deaths stabbed them in the heart of an
obsidian knife offering their bodies to
their newborn son as the last God made
the sacrifice Lord ket's alcoa blew the
embers of the great fire back to life
and the Sun began to move through the
sky at last assuring in the fifth page
thanks to a pimply weakling whose
fortitude inspired all the other gods
the Sun moves along its daily path the
rabbit faced moon following in its wake
if you enjoyed this myth check out this
playlist for more epic tales
[Music]